The following was recorded from inside an ice plunge Okay, all right When a core's life is cold enough the mountains on the can turn blue So the next time you want to cold loggered cold filtered cold package Core's light just wait until those glorious mountains on the can turn blue. Whoo, it's easy to say that fast when you're freezing gold. Spring is here and you can now get almost anything you need
delivered with Uber Eats. What do we mean by almost? You can't get a well-groomed lawn delivered, but you can get chicken parmesan delivered. Sunshine? No. Some wine? Yes. Get almost, almost anything delivered with Uber Eats. Order now.
Alcohol in select markets. See app for details. Order now. Alcohol in select markets. See after details. Hello everyone. Hi there. Welcome to a little Friday chit chat. We were not expecting to do a Friday chit chat today, but Angela, as you and I were coming into the building, we solved a major Friday chit chat mystery.
Well, here's what happened, you guys. We arrived at the same time and we got into the elevator. There was one other lady in it. She had hit floor number eight and Jenna, like I look and our floor is not lit up. So I'm like, did you hit the button? And she turns to me and goes, no, I hit floor number two. And I said, what? I said, I want to see this man in the low chair. And I said, he's probably not there. It was probably like an anomaly. Like, what are the odds? But we got off on the second floor and we turned.
And I did this. Because guess what? Man in low chair was there. But I was like, and is this the man in the low chair you were talking about? Because this is not how I imagined it. And I said, it wasn't low enough for you? It was just, tell me you guys, Sam Cassie,
when Angela told the story, did you imagine that there was a, like a business man doing business at his like businessy desk in a super low chair? I think I pictured who ran Potterstown in It's a Wonderful Life. I don't know. The old man, the evil old man.
I just pictured him, but like two feet lower in his chair. Okay. Cassie? I just think this building is full of like artists and weirdos that I think it could be anything. Okay. Thank you, you guys. See, there's several interpretations. I like this. And here's the thing.
Jenna said, is that the same man? And I said, no, it's several interpretations. I like this. And here's the thing. Jenna said, is that the same man? And I said, no, it's not. It's a new man in a low chair. But there's also a lady outside this time in a low chair in the hallway who looked right at me when I went, oh, like. Also, I, okay, go on, go on. Now.
That's as far as I got. Listen, that day when I came in, I was, go on. Now that's as far as I got. Listen, that day when I came in, I was in a rush. Yeah. You got off at the wrong floor, accidentally saw a man in a low chair, got back on the elevator. Exactly. I didn't take a lot of time to look.
Okay, well, it was just, it was just a waiting room for a dental office and people were just in chairs and they weren't particularly low. Lower than you would expect though. Were they though? They seemed like regular chairs. I mean they just seem like people sitting in chairs waiting for their dental work.
If you've never seen a door open in this whole building the whole time we've been here and you get off the elevator thinking you're on your floor and there's a door open and a man in a little chair. You keep saying little chair, but it's a regular chair. Here's the thing, the guy I saw, the original guy, was very tall. So put him in that chair with his long legs. Okay, fair enough. Anyway, guys, it's a dentist office.
If you need to get your teeth cleaned, there's one on the second floor. Okay. Um, we have more news. Another update. We won the Webby y'all. Yes, we did. Thank you to everybody. Yes.
Thank you so much for voting. We won the 2025 People's Voice Award for Best Comedy Podcast. Come on. Thank you so much to everyone for voting. You know, it felt so special to me. We won when the show first came out. And now to win again after all these years, we all worked so hard on the show.
And I was so moved by it. I was really moved by it. I sort of announced it to my family. I was like, we won a Webby. And they were like, oh my gosh. Well, the thing I love about it is I think it's the coolest looking of the awards. It looks like a spring. It's like a spindle like a spiral, spirally thing. It's very visually interesting. I know. I love it. Now we have two. Yay. I have another chit chat topic that I was excited to bring to the group. Okay.
I want to talk about a skincare product that I'm really enthusiastic about. Okay. Go on. Yeah, you have us. It is inexpensive. You can buy it at the drug store and it's Aquaphor. Okay. I love Aquaphor. Yeah, Aquaphor is great.
You said you love Aquaphor, Sam. Tell me more. I use it on all my tattoos afterwards. Yeah. It's great. What does it do? It's like a barrier. It's greasy.
It's like Vaseline. It's a petroleum jelly. And it's great for sunburns. Okay, that's where I think I've heard it. Yes, and it holds moisture in and creates a barrier, but I started using it when I was doing radiation and my doctor said I should slather myself in aquaphor and sleep in it.
She's like, it's hard to wear during the day because it's kind of greasy. But I was like, amazing. My daughter got a sunburn, we threw some aquaphor on it. I was like, hey, radiation lady said this is the best thing for burns. Put it on her. But then, not to go too deep into my medical side effects,
but at one point, I got this really bad rash. Remember, lady? All over my neck. All over your neck. And all over, kind of up encroaching on my face. I do. And the dermatologist said, put some aquaphor on it. So I started slathering my face and chest and neck and aquaphor. And then when the rash went away, I got gifted like a fancy schmancy
face cream. And guess what happened? Rash. Thank you, Cassie. I broke out into a rash again. And then I started using the aquaphor again. And then blah, blah, blah. I had to have my makeup professionally done. And the makeup artist was like, what skincare do you use? Your skin is luscious. Your skin is beautiful. It's never been this beautiful.
And she's known me for years. And I said, aqua four. So there it is. I'm putting it out in the world. You don't need fancy schmancy. Don't pass aqua four up. Don't sleep in the aqua four. Now with the sleeping,
do you get in like an aqua four sleeping bag? No. Brim, we will picture you so tight in the top. So Lee doesn't get covered in grease. No, I put it on like about an hour before I go to bed. So it's not as like potent. Like, I love the visual though, because it's like, you know, like how your grandma used to sleep
in gloves with lotion. I love the idea that you have a special sleeping sack for when you are up. So soft. Yes. Now listen, I'm not a skin expert, believe it or not. You're not? I'm not.
I'm also not a dermatologist. I thought that was the extra degree you did. No, I never finished it. Oh, OK. Not an anesthetician, but so there could be a thing where I run dry in general. My skin runs dry, it's always parched. I drink a ton of water.
My skin is always so thirsty. So if you have like an oily skin or you're prone to breakouts, maybe don't take my aquifer advice or ask a professional, but I really love it. It's probably good in dry climates too. Like we live in a dry climate. We do.
That's a good point. Yeah. Yeah. This might be a whole different conversation if you lived like in Scotland. Or Florida. Oh. Florida is very moist.
Muggy. Muggy. Right? Yeah. Well, I have a hot travel tip for everybody. Yeah. Ready? Yeah. Should you find yourself in the Phoenix Airport in the Southwest Terminal? Okay. There's a display of all of these handmade quil around taking pictures of quilts and reading the little plaques. And it's so beautiful. I thought, how wonderful, how nice.
You guys are looking at me kind of blank. It's snow, it's really sweet. I was waiting for the point of the story to kick in. That's it, Sam. It's an appreciation of art at the Southwest Terminal in Phoenix. Yeah, my thought was, this is just very on brand for Angela. Yeah.
If I was to run into you in the wild, it would be looking at quilts. Well, I took all the pictures, I took pictures of all of them. Yeah, I wouldn't be surprised if you missed your following three connected nights. You know, the funny thing is there was a family, like clearly they're on a big family trip.
I imagined it was like a big family reunion or for a wedding. There was multiple generations of age and they were taking a huge group photo like, we're on our way. But they were right in front of one of the quotes I wanted to take a picture of. So I sort of scooched behind them to get my picture and then I saw them, they looked over their shoulder like what the f**k this lady weren't you clearly trying to take a group picture and she's like behind us reading the quilt plaque and I turned I was like oh I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry but anyway um there you go little hot tip for you. I love that hot tip um if you were a travel blogger that would be
a very unique travel tip. Thank you. There are a lot of airports that have lovely art features that really help pass the time. Yeah. And then there's the Denver Airport, which is like conspiracy town. What? What's happening at the Denver Airport? I mean, I'm in that airport all the time.
Supposedly built by a bunch of Freemasons if I'm telling the story, right and it's supposedly there's like a bunch of hidden Messages written all over in it. The artwork is really strange in there Yeah, and then they're outside of the airport is like this horse statue. Yes to get it There is like such a long Weird tragic story to get the horse statue the such a long, weird, tragic story. To get the horse statue, the big blue one? Yeah, and it's really scary. It looks like a horse that's like...
Well, yeah, scary. Yeah. You know, listeners want to Google deep dive it. It's the Denver airport. It's just very strange. I'm literally there all the time because Josh's family. I'll have to look it up. Should we go there and like mom detective it? Yes. And see what the hidden messages are? We'll also need to visit Josh's family
because we'll have to make an extended stay. That's fine. OK. Google search says, the Denver International Airport conspiracy theories revolve around the idea that the airport is somehow a hub for sinister activities, including secret government plans, new world order agendas, theories revolve around the idea that the airport is somehow a hub for sinister activities, including secret government plans, new world order agendas, or even alien involvement.
Oh my goodness. You know what I've always thought of the Denver Airport? What? Now this might go to my love of chocolate meringue pie, but I just, we call it the pie airport because it looks like the top, it looks like chocolate meringue. Ooh. Oh. So that was my take on the Denver Airport. Wow. I've got to do some Googling now.
I wonder if Josh's family's ever heard about this. Maybe. It seems like it would have come up in conversation once over all these years. I got stranded at the Denver Airport once with my two kids and I found everyone in the airport to be really nice For what it's worth. Yeah, I mean I've had no issues Well, I'm intrigued Before we wrap up Friday chit chat, I do feel like we need to say happy birthday today's Cassie's birthday We will have treats and fun later Today's Cassie's birthday! Yes, happy birthday Cassie. Happy birthday! Thank you everyone.
We will have treats and fun later. And I also want to give a shout out to my parents who came in the studio and helped us open up and organize fan mail. They helped us put up stuff. Finally, my dad hung up our special plaque award thing from Spotify that we got for our 100 million Spotify downloads.
Yes, we didn't know how to hang it because it's a concrete wall. But your dad had all the tools and I walked in and he was on a ladder. It was amazing. And then we also, I finally got to hang up Sam's gift of us with Keanu. Yes.
So now that is above my desk. But yeah, so we got all decorating done and thank you to my folks for coming in. Yeah. All right. Well, do you guys have any additional chatty? We good. Cassie, what are you doing for your birthday? I'm playing pickup basketball with a bunch of my friends.
So fun. And then right now, the NBA is in playoffs, and my partner and I are Clippers fans. So they're playing tonight, and we're going to group for them. So fun. Yeah, just a lot of basketball and office ladies, which I can't complain. Sam, you had your birthday one week ago. I did, yeah.
Which we celebrated. Thank you. Did you end up going to that Italian restaurant that Lee used to be a waiter at? Pergoletta, yes I did on Hillhurst Avenue in California. Yeah I did. It's my favorite restaurant in Los Angeles. It's so good. I've never been. I want to go. It's great. I'll take you. Yay! All right. Well there's some office ladies chit chat for you guys. We hope you have a great Friday. And we'll see you next week. Bye. Bye. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fischer and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.